[Música]
más romeros a la hablamos ahora de salud
actualizamos la situación del brote de
la viruela del mono qué novedades
tenemos pues buenos días raúl para
empezar es un proto que sigue creciendo
las últimas cifras de la organización
mundial de la salud cifra en los casos
en 550 en 30 países donde la enfermedad
no es endémica pero es que una de las
cosas más importantes que dijo la oms en
sus actualizaciones estas pues casi que
diarias que hacen es que creen que hubo
una transmisión durante un periodo de
tiempo indeterminado previo a que se
detectaran estos casos y eso explicaría
pues que surgieran en varios países a la
vez otra de las novedades es que nos
lleva a inglaterra pero por otros
motivos es que finalmente la agencia de
salud inglés ha dicho que hay
transmisión comunitaria por primera vez
en el país es decir que pues el virus se
ha transmitido de persona en persona sin
que todos estos casos estén ligados a un
viaje a un país donde la enfermedad es
endémica
marc y esta cifra de más de 500 casos
realmente es una cifra que preocupante
que deberíamos preocuparnos por esto
después nosotros queríamos ponerla un
poco en perspectiva para que cada uno
claro así haga sus propias conclusiones
no obviamente es inusual que suceda 500
casos en países no endémicos pero cuando
lo comparamos con las cifras de los
países donde esta enfermedad así es
endémica la verdad es que vemos pues que
la proporción es bien distinta no
estamos hablando de estos 550 casos en
30 países en un total de 30 países pero
es que solo en los 7 en 7 países
africanos donde esta enfermedad es
endémica se calcula que han habido
1400 casos confirmados más del doble en
lo que va de 2020 además hay miles más
de casos sospechosos que no se han
podido confirmar pues debido a falta de
recursos también justo recientemente en
un acto de la organización mundial de la
salud cifraba en el 95 los bordes
sospechosos que ha habido sólo en
república central africana en 20 años en
2000 entre 2001 y 2021 y sobre todo pues
estas 70 muertes 70 70 víctimas mortales
que también nos muestra como la tasa de
mortalidad es mucho más alta si hacemos
la proporción es como si 28 personas
hubieran muerto en este brote en los
países europeos y pues desarrollados en
los que ha llegado estas cifras de hecho
han levantado ciertas críticas de
médicos con sables sanitarios del
continente africano pues porque este
nivel de alarma y de movilización se
está dando ahora que la enfermedad ha
llegado a los países desarrollados pero
pues han habido 70 personas como hemos
dicho que han perdido la vida en países
africanos por esta misma enfermedad
desde que inició el año y eso no ha
generado ningún tipo de respuesta
hablando de respuesta marca y
movilización hay para frenar realmente
este brote no que a lo mejor en otro
país no se sigan transmitiendo de manera
comunitaria como ya lo estamos viendo el
reino unido- por supuesto pues
obviamente la vacunación está sobre la
mesa sobre todo con las vacunas de
viruela humana que se ha visto que
funcionan contra la vida del mono
también esto ya está pasando en
reinounido en eeuu también sobre todo
para contactos cercanos o personal
médico pero es que esto también ha
suscitado críticas porque pues porque la
organización mundial de la salud ha
empezado a barajar la posibilidad de dar
de sus vacunas de las reservas que
tienen de las vacunas contra la viruela
en caso de que hubiera un rebrote de
esta viruela humano y entonces pues
muchos están diciendo que estas reservas
nunca se consideró movilizarlas para los
muertes que ha habido en el continente
africano repasemos también las cifras de
estas reservas de vacunas hay 24
millones en suiza en la sede de la
organización mundial de la salud y luego
hay reservas nacionales de varios países
que se han comprometido también a
donarlas en caso de que se necesiten
estamos hablando de francia alemania
reino unido eeuu y también nueva zelanda
en total 31 millones de dosis entre
estos países también esto dibuja un poco
este mapa de la desigualdad no al final
vemos que los países que tienen las
vacunas que podrían frenar estos brotes
son las que realmente no los han
necesitado hasta ahora claro marc usted
ha hablado de la ms y la organización
hizo una nueva advertencia no sí una
advertencia que debemos escuchar para el
futuro empecemos por ahí
y sin lugar a dudas hay más presión
ecológica en el sistema los animales
están cambiando su comportamiento los
humanos también en general lo que vemos
es que está hiper endemicidad como en
las enfermedades endémicas a niveles más
pequeños cada vez son más persistentes
más frecuentes y generan más y más
brotes y creo que ahí hay una elección
no solo para la vida del mono entonces
esto cambio climático deforestación
cambio de comportamientos no también más
conectividad entre comunidades y entre
países está provocando estos cambios de
comportamiento y está haciendo que cada
vez haya más enfermedades que saltan de
animales a humanos y que luego además se
extiendan más que los brotes sean cada
vez más grandes repasemos brevemente
unas cifras según un estudio de que
publicó la revista en hecho desde 1940
se han detectado 334 casos de
enfermedades infecciosas emergentes un
ejemplo sin ir más lejos es el vih o el
ébola enfermedades que conocemos bien no
y esto década tras década además ha ido
en aumento porque pues también porque
estamos acelerando el cambio climático
estamos acelerando la deforestación y
para y raúl terminando otra vez
volviendo al tema de las desigualdades
vemos que es que los lugares donde es
más probable que aparezcan estas nuevas
enfermedades infecciosas como el
continente africano por ejemplo en
primer lugar son los países que menos
responsabilidad tienen en caso del
cambio climático y de la deforestación
pero es que además también son los que
menos recursos tienen para controlar
monitorear y responder a posibles
potenciales de brotes en el futuro
entonces pues distribuir equitativamente
no solo las vacunas de los tratamientos
sino también los recursos son lo que
hace que finalmente nos beneficiemos a
todos en el futuro y yo diría que más
allá de acelerar el cambio climático o
el desastre que estamos haciendo nos
estamos destruyendo más muchísimas
gracias entonces por toda la información
de salud nosotros continuamos estrés
directo américa